the surging number of new coronavirus
cases in the u.s has broken a record set
one day earlier by almost 20 thousand
officials reported nearly look at the
number behind me 122
000 cases yesterday alone the day after
passing
100 000 for the first time many states
in the midwest are also setting records
for new infections
adriana diaz is in milwaukee that's one
of the hardest hit areas in the country
adriana good morning to you what is the
situation where you are
good morning gail well we're outside
miller park where the brewers play
and this is milwaukee city's largest
community testing site
here in wisconsin they have different
categories for measuring virus activity
ranging from low
to very high and gail right now all of
the state's
72 counties are at that top very high
level for virus activity
and this as the virus continues to
spread across the midwest
i cannot stress enough the severity of
our situation
illinois governor jb pritzker says his
state's coveted cases are rising faster
than they have since
june hitting a new single day record of
more than 9 900 cases
while covet-related deaths passed the 10
000 mark in the state
the rise in cases and hospitalizations
is unsustainable the numbers continue to
rise dramatically across the country
in all 15 states broke single day
records for new covet cases on thursday
seven of them are in the midwest
wisconsin officials are calling it a
crisis
with hospitals at or near capacity
statewide
former cdc director dr tom frieden we're
seeing
lots of spread from pizza parties
after school parties people getting
together
and spreading not just goodwill but
unfortunately
a lot of virus she just started her
senior year in high school
susan 3 iron says her 17 year old
daughter elvia
who was asthmatic and had high blood
pressure is the youngest person in north
dakota to die from covet complications
she was pretty much my other helper
as a parent they live on a native
american reservation where there are
limited medical resources
after first going to an area hospital
elvia was eventually airlifted to fargo
her mother susan was then diagnosed with
covet herself
and also had to be hospitalized she was
watching elvia on a video link
when her daughter's heart stopped your
daughter passed away while you were
also at the hospital with kovid yes
they put the phone beside her i told her
i love her
so she could rest now and be at peace
she also told her that she was proud to
be her mother guys
her daughter was just 17 years old it
was a really hard interview
with her and this is a really important
point according to the cdc
cases among native americans and alaska
natives are three and a half times
greater than among
white americans and susan three irons
said on her reservation there's no
hospital
they're only clinics so they cannot
treat severe cases
anthony that's such a concern that must
have been a heartbreaking interview
adriana thank you
and some really scary trend lines right
now